how you doing guys today we have a 2017
Hyundai Sonata Hybrid uh the customer
have a uh key that uh currently it
doesn't work and we're going to create a
new key uh from scratch let's get
started so the first thing I'm going to
find the OPD and I'm going to put the
dungle of the hotel km 100
um I'm going to um start with the main
menu we're going to go to
immobilizer and I'm going to look for
Hyundai it tells me that I need to
connect to the dongle with Bluetooth so
we're going to connect it in a
second after it's been connected I'm
going to hit uh automatic selection the
ignition doesn't work so it's not going
to read the VIN number unless I put it
next to the ignition and now I can read
the VIN number her key the proximity
stopped
working so it's going to read the VIN
number I'm going to hit
okay we need to choose USA then it shows
us all the ear making model we're going
to hit yes by the way if you like those
videos don't forget to like And
subscribe so you can see my videos that
I upload occasionally we're going to go
to control unit and first we need to
read the PIN code now this is an 8A chip
so we need to read the PIN code with 8 a
uh he tells me I need an internet turn
on the hazard lights and turn off the
ignition hit okay oh and then you tell
me also to close the
door so we're going to hit
okay connected to the
internet it says that it might take a
long time it doesn't take that
[Music]
long
and here we have six digigit pin code
we're going to hit okay and we're going
to go escape from this
menu and we're going to go to the
keyless
system and we're going to go to remote
control
learning we're going to open the
door I'm going to go to Smart Key
learning it tells me that uh that's
going to anyways deleted so we'll have
to write both of them together tells me
to turn ignition off and open and close
the driver door we're going to hit okay
it already registered the pin that he
just read verify that this is the right
pin and now it tells me within 5 seconds
after I press okay I need to put the uh
the smart fob that I want to learn next
to the
ignition okay so this was not it because
we need to press on it so I'm going to
do it one more time and we're going to
hit
okay and we're going to press press it
in and it tells me that it succeeded I'm
going to hit yes for the next key hit
okay and press the start button with the
fob programming succeeded we have two we
don't want anymore so we have two keys
in the memory we'll hit okay so um now
everything is programmed the chip to
start and the remote and let's test it
[Music]
out that works nice and easy uh don't
forget to like And subscribe let me know
in the comments below if you have any
questions about the device the car or
any other locksmith question uh now I'm
going to use SEC E9 key cutting machine
high security machine to duplicate um
the blade the emergency blade um the
reason for the Emergency blade is only
for the door in case the car batter is
died you can open the car manually with
the with the door I'm going to go to the
menu I'm going to look for automobile
I'm going to look for Hyundai Sonata and
I'm going to go up to 2011 and up and
I'm going to hit the code on the
menu and let the machine decode the key
[Music]
by the way my machine have the cover
removed from the whole system over there
because I have a I had a problem with
the uh belt I had to fix so uh I had to
open up the cover and fix it anyways
after it finished uh um let's do the
decoding again because it wasn't sitting
on the right direction as you can see
I'm adjus in my uh my belt over
[Music]
there the two um the two sides of the
key have different cuts so is going to
read like each side
differently and um and then we can cut
the
key what I want to make sure that after
that I uh decoded I want to make sure
that all the numbers on this screen are
blue if they are red that means they are
not good over here I can see that some
of them are not good so I'm going to
round it up so now everything is round
up I'm going to match the picture I'm
going to hit okay on the screen and then
I'm going to match the picture with the
key that she
have well the the the numbers are
matching based on what I look so I'm
going to put the new one hit okay hit
cut speed up the cutter and cut
[Music]
again after you finished cutting the top
side of the key I'm going to clean it up
the clamp and the key flip it over and
cut the second
side after finished cutting the the key
on both sides we can uh clean up one
more time the key and the clamp
and we can go ahead and test it uh in
the door
lock so first of all we're going to test
the remote because we are outside so
we're going to lock
it open the
trunk looks like everything is working
the right way unlock it everything works
checking the proximity it works as
well and try to start the
car and everything works the way it
should uh the last thing we're going to
check we're going to check the door lock
just to make sure that we cut the key
correctly and that works amazing guys
thank you for watching and uh I'll hope
to see you in the next
video